[Musik]
am morgigen Tag führt die vierte panz
Brigade federführend die Parade
anläslich der Musterung an der
Theresianischen Militärakademie durch
diese Parade wird erstmalig seit den
letzten 5 Jahren wieder durchgeführt es
werden an dieser Parade knapp 1000
Soldaten und Soldatinnen teilnehmen und
zusätzlich wird die Parade um die 200
Fahrzeuge umfassen davon ist der
vorzuheben dass wir über 80 gepanzerte
kampahrzeuge haben die an der Parade
teilnehmen werden und über Luftfahrzeuge
die ebenfalls Teil dieser Parade sein
werden wir sind hier beim
Kommandofahrzeug der des Treffens der
schweren Kräfte wir sind heute
eingetroffen hier bei einem traumhaften
Wetter um das vorüben für die morgige
Parade durchzuführen so viele
mechfahrzeuge wie schon lang nicht mehr
bei Paraden eingesetzt worden sind wir
gesamt eine grenadiercompanie eine
panzercompanie eine Artillerie
haizenbatterie und die
versorgungselemente die hier den
Abschluss D bilden werden und wir freuen
uns schon morgen hier ein würdiges Event
für unsere auszumusternden Leuten an
Durchführen des sie sich in drei Jahren
verdient haben und morgen einen würdigen
Abschluss ihrer Ausbildung dann
dementsprechend auch stattfinden wird
und ich freue mich schon es ist auch für
uns für das SP 35 eine Ehre und
Auszeichnung dass wir hier das
treffenkommando
dementsprechend ihnen haben und unsere
Soldaten sind alle super motiviert es
ist die beste Stimmung und wir freuen
uns auf den
morgenag